nebia is a revolutionary shower head
that saves you money by using
45 percent less water but with a stream
of water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15
off go to nebia.com pacman and use the
code pacman
we have one of those big if true type of
announcements yesterday president joe
biden announced that there will be
enough vaccine supply
for every adult in the united states to
get a coronavirus vaccine
by the end of may now there will be
enough supply
and we will have the resources to inject
every dose or two different things
but we'll talk about that let's look at
the announcement from joe biden made
yesterday afternoon we're now on track
to have enough vaccine supply
for every adult in america by the end of
may
let me say that again when we came into
office
the prior administration had contracted
for not nearly enough vaccine to cover
adults in america
we rectified that about three weeks ago
we were able to say
that we'll have enough vaccine supply
for adults by the end of july
and i'm pleased to announce today as a
consequence of the stepped-up
process that i've ordered and just
outlined
this country will have enough vaccine
supply i'll say it again
for every adult in america by the end of
may
by the end of may that's progress
important progress but it's not enough
to have the vaccine supply
we need vaccinators people to put the
shots in people's arms
so what exactly does this mean there
will be enough
vaccine doses for every adult to get
vaccinated
is this possible is it an over promise
there's a number of different
considerations here and let's just kind
of think it through apply the sniff test
to it
first of all remember that right now
every american
is mostly every adult two of the
vaccines are for 18 plus
currently authorized for 18 years of age
and older individuals
the other is for 16 plus so roughly
when we say every american right now we
mean
every eligible american which is
somewhere between
260 and 266 let's call it 265 million
people
if we start with those eligible age-wise
for the vaccine so we're starting with
265.
then we look at as of today march 3rd
what is the number of people who are
vaccinated in other words we start with
the 265
how many are all set and we can remove
from that well 26 million people got
both doses so that drops us from 265
to 239 million eligible americans
left to vaccinate of the 239 million
that are left
an additional 25 and a half 26 million
have one dose from the vaccines that
need
two doses so we need to get those 26
million people to 100 vaccination
we need another 26 million doses so then
we will have 213 million people
left to vaccinate in the remainder of
march
april and may 213 million people
in what is roughly 89 days that's a big
stretch
but there's more considerations here
joe biden is saying not that we
will vaccinate every eligible american
by the end of may
he's saying we will have enough vaccines
by the end of may and it could take time
from vaccine availability to actual
injection so that's one aspect of this
we also have to probably take off the
top
that right now about 25 of adults don't
want the vaccine that's the latest
number it's been declining over time
more and more people want the vaccine
over time
but in reality it's not really 213
million people left to vaccinate it's
more like 198 million
when you account for those who as of
right now say that they don't want it
so the question becomes will there be
doses for 198 million people
to be vaccinated by the end of may even
if it takes them a little longer to get
vaccinated in theory yes it's not crazy
to think that that's a number that's
going to be available moderna and pfizer
continue to say they will deliver enough
together to cover 200 million americans
by the end of may that would be 400
million doses
but that includes december january
february it includes what they've
already
done and then johnson and johnson the
recently
approved third vaccine which is a one
dose vaccine
they had contracted to deliver 87
million vaccines by the end of may
remember with being one dose
87 million vaccines is enough for 87
million people
but it looks like jnj is going to fall
short
but there's some breathing room even if
johnson and johnson does only a part of
the 87 million they contracted to do
it's quite plausible that you will have
enough vaccines for every
eligible american who wants a vaccine
by the end of may as i said earlier this
week
every indication if you look at both
what the biden administration is
claiming
and what the pharmaceutical companies
are claiming every indication
is that the challenge as we get into
april and
certainly it may even start to be a
challenge in march
certainly by the end of april and
definitively by may
the challenge will be do we have enough
infrastructure to put the vaccines into
arms because the amount of new days
doses we're going to have
in the next 80 days even in the next 40
days
is well beyond what we currently are
able to inject
we're going to need more vaccination
sites which are being launched
we're going to need more vaccinators who
are being hired
and we may be needing to run some of
these larger vaccination sites 24
7 to make this happen having enough
vaccines by may 31st
is great if you can't actually inject
them
for four months then it's sort of like
well it's actually going to be four more
months
now one important thing to know and this
may
increase the number of people that want
the vaccine the cdc
is expected to announce tomorrow
thursday march 4th
that it's okay they're going to give a
go-ahead
for vaccinated people to gather
indoors in small groups without masks
this may encourage more people to want
the vaccine and it may lower
the vaccine hesitancy remember at one
point 60 didn't want the vaccine
that was down to 50 40 33 now it's down
to about 25.
the cdc saying hey we've determined
these vaccines are effective enough
that vaccinated people groups of
exclusively vaccinated people small
groups and doors without masks are okay
that will likely encourage more people
to say i want the vaccine now at the
same time
the counter would be if you care what
the cdc says you probably already want
the vaccine you're already in the group
of people that want it
so maybe it won't make that big of a
difference i don't know
if the cdc is going to convince too many
anti-vaxxers that at this late stage
still don't want the vaccine but it's
something uh people who have been fully
vaccinated
against covet 19 will be cleared
to gather in small groups without masks
dr anthony fauci said yesterday quote
i use the example of a daughter coming
in from out of town who is doubly
vaccinated
and a husband and wife doubly vaccinated
and maybe a next-door neighbor
who you know are doubly vaccinated small
gatherings in the home
of people i think you can clearly feel
that the relative risk is so low
that you would not have to wear a mask
that you could have a good
social gathering within the home that is
very good news that is very optimistic
news and i find it completely reasonable
now it goes without saying that if this
new vaccine timeline is accurate
we are again we i want to be
realistically optimistic based on what
we're being told
we are looking at a potentially very
good summer all else being equal
assuming we don't have significant
variant escape from the vaccines and all
of the things that we're watching we're
potentially looking
at a pretty solid summer and we will
continue to cover it
the united states has now fully
vaccinated about 8 percent of the
population
texas has fully vaccinated just under
seven percent of the population so of
course
republican texas governor greg abbott
has decided open
everything wide open end the mass
mandates
and let her rip to quote anthony fauci
from last year
governor abbott tweeting about this
yesterday saying quote
i just announced texas is open one
hundred percent
everything i also ended the statewide
mass
mandate he at the briefing made this
announcement
much the same way to applause take a
look at this
so today i'm issuing a new
executive order that rescinds most of
the earlier executive orders
effective next wednesday all
businesses of any type
are allowed to open 100 percent
that includes any type of entity in
texas
also i am ending the statewide
mask mandate now did federal health
officials suggest this be done
no they did not uh federal health
officials said the opposite they said do
not ease restrictions quite yet
not enough people are vaccinated the
case reductions
are sort of leveling off this is not the
time to do that
but greg greg abbott doesn't care uh and
maybe uh
yeah i mean at this point maybe return
to smoking in restaurants as well right
if the argument here is freedom from
texas governor greg abbott now i have a
few thoughts on this
big picture this is completely and
incredibly premature
it's completely irresponsible it makes
no sense to do
that being said one element of this
is i wonder how much it will actually
change people's behavior in texas
because
all along you had lots of people in
texas ignoring the guidelines
and the people who are paying attention
to the cdc and fauci and the white house
are probably not going to change what
they're doing because of greg abbott's
announcement so
there's a real question as to how much
this will actually change in texas it
will change some things
i wonder how much that being said i can
understand
and sympathize with the urgency of
getting
businesses open for the sake of business
or at least wanting to the mask mandate
seems like just utter virtue signaling
to the anti-mask
crowd wearing a mask is so easy
you could open the businesses fully but
keep the mask mandate
and make it all safer so the mask
mandate ending
seems to me far more political than it
is even economic but it is texas and
that's clearly a big part of what
they're doing
the next question is whether this is
destined to backfire
what i mean by that is is it too early
of course it is
is it against the medical
recommendations is it against public
health recommendations what texas is
doing
of course are enough people vaccinated
where there's a mathematical case to be
made for doing this
no no chance in hell but
texas has the benefit of it being warm
in much of the state we know about the
storms warm in much of the state
getting warmer as we approach spring
just three weeks away
the virus is generally speaking on a
downturn
and vaccinations are increasing so as
bone-headed
as this decision is by governor greg
abbott
there's a chance that they may merely
by odds get away with this without
as big of a disaster as we might imagine
assuming that vaccination continues and
of course the people most at risk
who understand the virus are probably
going to keep being safe anyway
so the case increases that this will
likely lead to in texas
probably are going to come mostly from
younger people
who behave less safely and will be
vaccinated later
but that might not be affecting
hospitalizations too much since young
people are unlikely to end up in the
hospital if they get sick
now some will some old folks will get
sick and die because of this
some random young people will too but
overall
texas has 29 million people
statistically
this is an irresponsibly early decision
to be making
but they might by chance get away with
it without
as big a disaster as this would have
been if they had done it for example
in october of 2020. this is the governor
making it official remember that the
mask mandate wasn't enforced in many
parts of texas anyway
people were already dining indoors so
it's quite possible that in some general
sense greg abbott is going to be able to
come out of this
vindicated and i use that term very
loosely thanks to the fact
that a lot of the guidelines the numbers
in texas already reflect a lot of
guidelines being ignored anyway
and vaccination and warmer weather is
only going to help that being said doing
this right before spring break
there's going to be some chaos and other
states clearly are starting to go in
this direction
a mississippi announcing yesterday
almost at the exact same time
they are lifting business capacity
limits they are lifting their mass
mandate and i predict
there will be more states to come it
strikes me as premature
it seems to me the more cautiously
optimistic timeline would be
let's go really hard the next 60 to 90
days on vaccination
and we could have for many aspects
aspects of the population in much of the
country
a close to normal summer maybe a lot of
states doing this will prevent us from
having that i don't know
but that's the news out of texas let me
know if you live in texas
will you change your behavior as a
result of this you can find me
on twitter at deepakman the david pakman
show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors today is nebia the
creator of the world's most
innovative shower head it uses only
about
half the water that other shower heads
do saving you money helping the
environment
but it's actually a lot more powerful
than other shower heads on the market it
has twice the coverage of other shower
heads
the water sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home i love it
only took a few minutes to set up really
easy and it's been a totally different
experience
than any other shower head i've used i
can get in and out of the shower way
quicker now
because of how powerful it is it only
takes a few seconds to get completely
rinsed off
so i was actually amazed that it's only
using about half as much
water nebia also offers a number of
shower accessories like shelves and
curtains which match
perfectly with the design of the shower
head the shower head starts at just
199 but the first hundred people to go
to nebia.com
pacman and use code pacman will get
15 off all nebia products
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show is a viewer and
listener supported program
you can support the work we do and get
not only access to commercial free audio
and video feeds of the show but also
access to the daily members only bonus
show by signing up
at joinpackman.com all right this this
is not like a huge
win where we would throw a party and
cheer but we actually got some good news
which is that
joe biden's a budget nominee to run the
office of management
and budget near a tandem has had to
withdraw her nomination
because of opposition now from the
beginning i
said as we evaluated joe biden's
selections for all sorts of different
cabinet and other positions
nira tandon is a bad pick niro tandon
was joe biden's worst
pick i argued and joe biden
selected niro tandon to run the office
of management and budget
it was pretty clear early on that there
would be opposition not just from many
republicans but possibly even from some
democrats and indeed that opposition
from both democratic and republican
senators made it clear
that she was unlikely to be able to get
confirmed now
the reason let me see how i want to say
this
although it's good that she's not going
to go forward and get confirmed
the reason why most of the republican
and some of the democratic opposition
didn't like her
is kind of a bs reason and it's her
controversial tweets
in which she attacked all sorts of
different people she's attacked
and tweets everybody from bernie sanders
to many republicans and others
for me the reason nero tandon was a bad
pick was because
as someone affiliated with the center
for american progress
she represent she think about all the
things she didn't represent
niro tandon didn't represent
progressivism niro tandon didn't
represent
independence from the most corporate and
establishment interests within the
the democratic party she represented all
of the worst of democratic party
politics an
establishment uh centrist leaning
cow towing to the money sort of
individual who you were going to put in
charge of the budget
that was the source of my opposition i
didn't care that niro tandon had said
mean things about bernie i didn't care
about niro tandon's other tweets
the reason why so many democrat
republicans and even some democrats like
joe manchin
said that they don't like uh nira tandon
for this position
was mostly related to tweets where all
sorts of different people who clearly
didn't actually have any idea what niro
tandon was tweeting all along
uh sort of decided to grandstand on the
basis of oh look at this tweet that nira
tandon sent look at that tweet that nira
tandon
sent and ultimately it
became clear that niro tandon didn't
have the votes
joe manchin of an important
centrist swing vote among democrats in
the senate
said that her quote overtly partisan
statement would have a toxic and
detrimental impact on working
relationships between congress and the
office of management and budget
maine republican susan collins uh also
says that her quote past actions
demonstrated the kind of animosity biden
has pledged to transcend
and it became clear that they weren't
going to have the votes for her so
this is in a sense funny because on
day one i mean go back to my clip the
day after nira tandon was not nominated
i said not only do i think this is a bad
nomination
it's not clear to me she can get
confirmed because i believe there will
be opposition from republicans and
democrats
that's exactly what happened it was
predictable so it's not a huge
win but it's a win in the sense that
this was biden's worst nominee
and she's not going to be in the
position and that's a good thing the
next question becomes
who replaces tandon the front-runner is
believed to be
shalonda young a former staff director
for the house appropriations committee
she's been actively pushed by members of
the congressional black caucus
believed to be the replacement pick i
don't know much about
shalonda young we will learn about
shalonda young if indicia is the nominee
by the time you listen to today's show
maybe she will already have been made
the nominee
uh but as i said before this is not
you know i i don't know where this rank
like
if you said biden could have done
coveted relief
10 days in and nira tandon would be
director of office uh the office of
management and budget i might have said
that's a fair trade it would have been
like near attendance bad but i might
have traded it if you got me covered
relief really soon and now we're still
waiting on covey to relief and it's
march
it's a win it's just not feeling
like uh this is now the progressive
takeover of the biden presidency but i
think if
if you want to find something positive
in this
it would be that we can
as people to the left of biden
have an impact on the biden presidency
although again the reason that this
nomination
tanked is partially because republicans
didn't like her mean tweets which is not
exactly a progressive perspective but
that is what it is near attendance not
moving forward and that i can be very
glad about
we have now learned that donald and
melania trump received their coveted
vaccines at the white house in january
but kept it secret
i will talk a little bit about why it's
believed that they kept it secret but
unfortunately i think there is no way to
deny
that donald and melania trump keeping
their coveted vaccinations
secret for months led to some deaths
that could have been prevented and i'll
explain why momentarily
cnn reporting that trump and melania
received the covet 19 vaccine in january
this is per
a trump advisor talking to cnn it wasn't
clear
which of the vaccines they received it
wasn't clear how many doses they
received
and uh this was something that the
question of this
came up and it came up on my stream on
sunday as we were
covering donald trump's cpac speech uh
donald trump said everybody should get
the vaccine and of course
his goal in saying that was a political
goal in taking credit for the vaccine
saying hey i got us the vaccine
everybody should get it this immediately
raised the question
as donald trump told the audience the
vaccine is very
unpainful unusual choice of terms but
it's trump okay
it raised the question did trump get the
vaccine we know joe biden did
trump even mentioned it saying my work
on vaccines
got joe a vaccine and the question
became
did trump get the vaccine in december
the white house said
trump wasn't going to be given a vaccine
until it was recommended by the white
house medical team
and that trump was still receiving the
benefits of that antibody treatment he
got when he had
coveted 19 and that that was that
we've now learned that trump accepted
the vaccine
while still president at the white house
in january
no public fanfare no public announcement
and now the question is could lives have
been saved if it had been publicly
known that trump trump had been
vaccinated i believe that the answer is
yes
we won't ever know how many and we won't
ever be able to point to who
but one of the most vaccine hesitant
groups in the country
is republicans we previously spoke about
how folks without college degrees
black folks and republicans are the
three
most anti-coveted vaccine groups in the
country
for different reasons republicans have
much of their
opposition or lack of interest in the
covet vaccine
based in the constant disinformation
that came from donald trump's white
house
that this isn't that serious and that we
can get back to normal without a vaccine
and so on and so forth so there's no
doubt that there are
can we say thousands could we say tens
of thousands of republicans
who did not get vaccinated
had they known trump had been vaccinated
in january
many of them would have gotten a vaccine
and simply statistically speaking
some of them got coveted and died
because they didn't get the vaccine and
they would have had they known trump had
gotten it and was saying
in january everybody should get it
instead of waiting until
february 28th to say everybody should
get it we won't know exactly how many
we won't know exactly who but there is
no question that this is
the latest action by donald trump
that caused some deaths some deaths that
could have been prevented
we now have a study which suggests
40 of the coveted deaths during
the trump presidency were due to bad
policy
of course we were going to have many
deaths this ravaged
just about every country in the world
but
40 percent of them were because of bad
management by the federal government and
by state governments as well
uh and um certainly trump keeping his
vaccine a secret
for months only made that even worse
we will have more coverage of this on
the david pakman show instagram
find us there at david pakman show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get access to the world-famous
bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership
very very quickly at joinpackman.com
that's
join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by
all means use the coupon code better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
welcome back to the david pakman show
the new battle lines in the culture war
at least for the last 48 hours have
become
dr seuss now i'm going to play a bunch
of clips for you
if you haven't been following the latest
fake scandal
it is indeed dr seuss the children's
author um republicans are claiming that
dr
seuss has been banned canceled uh
in particular by a virginia school
district now first of all the story
is all based on a claim that's not true
read across america day is a day of
reading children's books historically
it had lots of dr seuss material in 2017
this
changed to be more diverse in 2019
a study looked at dr seuss books and
found that characters of color
are very underrepresented they make up
only two percent of the human characters
and that almost all of those
representations of minority characters a
play
on stereotypical tropes and portrayals
in particular
of asians and that's true there's no
question about that whatsoever
of course dr seuss books written in a
different era but there is no denying
that that is absolutely
the case so the virginia school district
they didn't ban dr
seuss they didn't burn any books they
did decide
not to connect read across america day
to dr
seuss specifically now some people were
happy
some people were not but dr seuss wasn't
banned dr
seuss wasn't canceled this is now
the issue to the right in fighting
this cancel culture war that is totally
trumped up and fabricated
and they are getting an insane amount of
mileage from it yesterday this is just a
few hours on fox news
okay think about everything that's been
going on in the world in the last 24
hours
and look at how much the story was dr
seuss on fox news
here is congressman jason chaffetz
appearing on fox to express
outrage jason jason where do you come
down give us 30 seconds
well i haven't gotten past the
assassination of mr potato head
that that one i still haven't gotten
past and now they're trying to take out
dr
seuss come on john these are these are
the icons i grew up with
yes fox ran a major segment during this
hour called
cancel culture comes for dr seuss
a fox news reporter asked biden press
secretary jen
saki about dr seuss chris you have
another question
about dr seuss it's maybe the only day
that you can bring up dr seuss
everything
uh it is national read across america
day it's also dr seuss's birthday
both former presidents obama and trump
mentioned
dr seuss in their read across america
day proclamations but president biden
did not why not
fox news characterized this portion of
the press briefing to stir up
even more controversy by captioning it
quote biden
whitehouse dodge's question on dr
seuss later in the day fox news tried to
stir up
more controversy by pointing out that
barack obama
once praised dr seuss let me just quote
barack obama in 2015 saying
quote pretty much all the stuff you need
to know is in dr
seuss now is barack obama racist for for
quoting dr
seuss there and and patting him on the
back for the work can i add one i don't
think so one other angle to this there
are so many kids right now we're falling
behind in their
reading because of this it's a great
place to start they're not
in the classroom and dr seuss this
company could be just spreading that
message
educate our children encourage literacy
um interesting stuff david it's good
enough for barack obama it's good enough
for me and the rest of america i think
then they do another segment on dr seuss
referring
uh to the um demand of congressman jim
jordan
to do congressional hearings on cancel
cancel culture vis-a-vis dr
seuss sports is also with us as well and
john from the political state this has
gotten this has gotten political
right because jim jordan has now stepped
in he's saying that there's a dangerous
trend happening with
canceled culture in this country he's
now calling on congress to examine this
canceled culture
that he says is sweeping america
you know everything is political these
days you know whether it's woke culture
whether it's cancer culture
whether it's extreme on either side here
but in the morning yesterday
they had reporter or anchor or i don't
know what role she is
carly shimkas reporting that six
dr seuss books will no longer be
published and have been cancelled
now it is true but it's dr seuss
enterprises that decided for itself
that as a business decision these six
books contain
hurtful stereotypical portrayals
of people so they decided for themselves
they're not going to publish them
anymore that's called
free market capitalism people can
complain or praise a company
and a company can listen to or ignore
those complaints but that's
free market capitalism news by the way
it's not just fox news max also jumping
in on the action
they ran a segment called cancel
culture's next target
dr seuss and then over on fox business
stuart varney running a defiant and
principal segment
simply called dr seuss cancelled
and then lastly well lastly for us i
could go on all day they went on into
the night
this morning they were back on dr seuss
but lastly for us
madison cothorn the trumpian republican
congressman recently accused
by oodles of women of sexual assault
he went on fox news yesterday not asked
about the endless sexual assault
allegations against him
but instead asked about dr seuss
and here is what he said anytime i'm
fired up about this
i don't know if you are but my guess is
if you had a childhood and you read dr
seuss you might be
president biden cancelling dr seuss in a
read across america proclamation this
after loudoun county schools there in
virginia
said his books are filled with quote
orientalism
anti-blackness and white supremacy
look congressman these cancellations get
more and more outlandish by the day when
does it stop
well brother i was going to go to the
gym after this hit but i don't have to
now i'm already fired up that is absurd
you know in inside of our congress we
actually
have done a lot we've got a lot
accomplished we have successfully so far
renamed a post office here in the 117th
congress
so you're telling me that the the actual
priorities of the democrats
is renaming a post office and now
canceling dr seuss
americans are actually struggling
they're really tired of this
but they won't stop covering it all day
day in and day out it continued into the
afternoon
into the evening during the 5 p.m show
on fox called the five
the headline story was six dr seuss
books pulled over offensive images
and what this is is simply what was
going we discussed it yesterday in
detail
some people weren't happy with my
analysis but many people
were and appreciated it they are losing
on every
issue americans think income inequality
is a problem that should be dealt with
americans are more in favor of abortion
being legal in most cases than ever
before
most americans think we should do covet
stimulus and do it the way that joe
biden and democrats have proposed
most americans believe gay marriage
should be legal i'm kind of hopping
around economic and cultural issues here
most americans believe that there should
be mask wearing for the time being like
i can go on
but republicans are statistically on the
wrong side of every
issue so it's dr seuss all day
and andrew cuomo if they want if they
want to do something that's marginally
more substantive in the way that they
cover it and there is an andrew cuomo
story and we covered it
and that's that's not the argument but
that is what is happening
on fox news at this point i could have
played 10 more clips from yesterday
i could have played five for from today
they will not stop with this issue
and then soon they'll move on to you
know maybe back to joe biden and jill
biden's relationship is fake that was
uh ten days ago they found a new shiny
object now
dr seuss um question for you
do you want me to keep engaging with
this
false idea of rampant cancel culture
or would you prefer i even start
ignoring it
as a critique of what the right is doing
open to hearing from you
some viewers sent me this clip yesterday
and i want to look at it with you today
evangelical end times televangelist
pastor preacher rick wiles
did a commentary a few days ago where
he sort of sounded almost kind of like
maybe a populist leftist
certainly a populist maybe even a
populist leftist who wants to
take money from billionaires to help the
poor and
some in our audience actually got
suckered into it
initially but if you actually listen to
what rick wiles is saying
and you understand the context of his
evangelical christian worldview
you realize he's merely being a
conspiracy theorist
and a nutty one at that it's plain
old-fashioned evangelical
end times conspiracy theorism which
sometimes can sound like it's left-wing
populism but it's not
now before we get into the clip as a
reminder we've talked about rick wiles
before
he's one of the guys who during the
trump administration was talking about a
civil war and taking up arms he's the
guy that said the impeachment of donald
trump is an attempted
jew coup he said if donald trump is
removed there will be violence i guess
he was right about that the violence was
from people on his side
he said vegan burgers are a satanic plot
to destroy
souls that's the rick wiles i'm talking
about so let's get into this clip
and you might notice he starts sounding
sort of kind of like a left-wing guy
here take a listen
if somebody in america
put together a political movement to do
two main things break up the power
of the tech companies i mean bust them
up
don't just
slap their fingers bust them up
break them up like in the monopolies of
the early 1990s i mean crush
the tech companies break them up and
to
outlaw being billionaires
okay he says let's break up tech
companies let's do antitrust enforcement
that's often a left-wing issue except
when they only
care about breaking up tech monopolies
and ignored the issue of antitrust for
decades
and then he said outlaw being a
billionaire
that's something many people on the left
have talked about so
so far right wing televangelist rick
wiles
is maybe appealing to some folks in our
audience but
let's continue we've reached a point
i mean i'm a free enterprise person and
and i i
have no um
no ill will towards anybody in their
financial success i
hey you want to be a zillionaire a
quadzillionaire i don't care
all right you want to go buy a planet go
buy planet i don't care
but when you use your money in power to
change my life
to take away my rights to try to force
things on me that i
object to that i find morally repulsive
when you try to restrict my free speech
when you try to promote
population control you want to pump
vaccines into my body
when you want to change society you know
what you're my enemy
you're my enemy and the only way you're
able to do it is because you're a
billionaire
so then we need to take away your
billions
bill gates if he was working a job
seven to five if he was going to work
like everybody else
bill gates wouldn't be doing this stuff
would he no he's only doing this stuff
because he's a billionaire
take his billions away take it away
we need to do it in this country there
needs to be a populist movement in this
country let's break up the tech
companies
let's take the billions give the bill
give their i want to take bill gates
billions and give it to the poor
so already by this point if you're a
clear thinking rational person
you should start to say this is this is
wacky right-wing stuff
it might be dressed up in left populist
sounding rhetoric but this is this is
this is wacky stuff
freedom for everyone until
and then he's off the rails anti-vaxx
conspiracies
decrying left-wing morality that he
claims is being imposed on him
he's already off the rails but maybe
some on the left might still be on board
but then rick gwyles goes fully
into anti-government anti-tax
rants take a look i want to give it to
the poor
i want to strip them completely strip
them and give it to the poor
i want jack dorsey's money i want
zuckerberg's money i want to give it to
the poor
i don't want to give it to the
government oh my gosh
tax them and and the government get it
no give it to the poor
let's take their money and give it to
the poor it's bust up their corporations
this country would change overnight so
now it's just standard right-wing
thinking
in in just a few minutes he gets into
the government sucks don't tax anyone
let's depend on charity to help the poor
exclusively
an old trope of the libertarian right
that's all this is and yet it's another
example of how populist
sounding rhetoric can fool a lot of
people
until you get to the solutions they
propose and the actions they take
this is the tucker carlson syndrome we
can call it
random person who doesn't understand
what fox news is doesn't understand
tucker carlson's background and all that
they tune into tucker's show and they
hear tucker ranting about
corporations and deletes doing bad
things to the little guy
and we were told that we were going to
have a reinvigoration of the working
class and all this stuff
wow that sounds almost like bernie and
then it gets to
careful black lives matter might take
your house
brown people coming in from mexico make
the country dirtier
literally a quote from tucker carlson
it's just another example
of that sweet sweet vocabulary
of the populist rhetoric that tricks
people
and then you get to the solutions they
propose and it's standard
radical right wing stuff yeah monopolies
are bad
billionaires are bad help the poor and
then
whoa what just happened here so there's
rick wiles
calling what i call the uh pulling what
i call
the old populist switcheroo
and actually tricking some people even
in my audience
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous
at this point and the daily commercial
free tv show by making those pledges at
patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us
on tv or even listen on the radio
patreon.com
slash david pakman show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
i didn't realize when i uh casually
mentioned uh
this monday and did a segment about
victimhood
and cancel culture on tuesday that this
was going to
continue blowing up to the degree that
it has we've already talked about the dr
seuss fiasco earlier on in the show but
now we have
another republican who has found
another way to portray herself as the
victim
in a completely unhinged and ludicrous
way for the party of personal
responsibility the modern republican
party seems to have
no trouble whatsoever finding
other people to blame for just about
everything
i'm talking now about trumpian q anon
congresswoman
marjorie taylor greene who gave a speech
yesterday
in the house of representatives where
she claimed that
when she has to wait in a line to go
through a metal detector to get into the
house chamber
that that is a form of voter suppression
now you're probably anticipating more of
an explanation from me about what she
means
there's no more this is what she said
take a listen to her
ranting and raving yesterday mr speaker
i rise in opposition to hr1
while we're talking about voter
suppression and long lines
i'd like to point out that there's real
voter suppression that happens right
here in congress
many members of congress have to stand
in long lines to enter the chamber going
through metal detectors emptying our
pockets
and being treated very disrespectfully
so that is real voter suppression and
it's a shame that it happens right here
on the house floor
standing in line to vote is not voter
suppression it's just part of the voting
process
just like people stand in line to buy
groceries at the grocery store
long lines to go through a metal
detector
to go into the house chamber is a form
of voter suppression
voter suppression and protecting
congress from someone carrying a gun
in the chamber are not the same thing
and in practice you know the the obvious
question here would be you know marjorie
to even plausibly accept what you're
saying
you would have to demonstrate that going
through the metal detector
has caused you or some of your
colleagues to miss a vote
in the house of representatives and of
course there's no evidence anybody
has missed a vote thanks to having to
wait a few minutes in line now to be
fair
she is one of the most ignorant people
in congress so it wouldn't come as a
huge shock that she may not understand
the difference between voter suppression
and standing in line for hours to vote
and not even being sure
if you'll be allowed because somebody
might have purged you from the voter
roll
there's that and then there's her
standing in line for a few minutes to
get into the house of representatives
as one of the most privileged
individuals in the united states
a member of a 1 out of 435 members of
the house
and having to just stand in line for a
few minutes there
and then she introduces this idea of
standing in line at the grocery store
and by the way if voting is like
going for groceries you can now get
groceries delivered
so why shouldn't you be able to get a
ballot delivered
which she's against but we'll skip that
layer of hypocrisy for today because
it's just another
rabbit hole one other thing though about
groceries
if marjorie taylor greene did have to
stand in line for groceries for as long
as some people have to stand in line to
vote
due to poll closures and understaffing
of polling places
you can be damn sure that marjorie
taylor green
would be demanding congressional action
immediately
on grocery store lines there's no
question about it it just hasn't
affected her personally yet
now i guess the the sort of real
question here is
is marjorie taylor green pretending not
to know the difference between these
things
and playing dumb for her ignorant
followers
or does she really not know i actually
can't tell anymore with these people
she also said that standing uh in line
at the house of representatives is voter
suppression
but standing in line to vote is not
voter suppression so like
even the arguments she's making are
internally conflicting it's a complete
and total mess she's a confused
individual painfully so and the crazy
thing is
her followers are even more confused
and they are the ones who fall for this
stuff and unless we make sure
that we again focus in on georgia in
2022 like we did in 2020
she may get herself re-elected um there
are there are concerns from republicans
that she may be facing a bloodbath
i would assume nothing trump if he's
able to raise money for that new pack
that he has that new grift
and uses the money to support marjorie
taylor green because she supports him
she may well be able to get herself
reelected and one of the main signals
that i've been
looking to um one of the bellwethers i
will be looking to in 2022 to signal
what the future of trumpism
may be is whether the trumpiest of
trumpian elected officials marjorie
taylor greene madison cother and lauren
bobert and others
do they get reelected in 2022 if they do
and they may
uh it will signal that in all likelihood
trumpism has much more staying power
than many of us would like to believe
i've been uh since november 4th
november 3rd now i don't even remember
was the election november 3rd or
november 4th
since the early november presidential
election we have covered
the goal post moves from the right
about when trump is coming back to power
and we are now hours from the next
milestone and
law enforcement is on alert over
concerns
that the q anon trumpian people may go
nuts when donald trump obviously does
not become president tomorrow
i'll tell you about that conspiracy
theory in a moment
as a reminder um i tell me if i'm
missing anything but
initially the claim was donald trump
won in early november and we will know
that when all the votes are counted
increasingly as it seemed that was not
the case the move was
we are going to file lawsuits in some
places to stop the count
in some places to keep counting even
though the ballots are all done being
counted there's no more ballots to count
and once that's done donald trump will
be announced
as the next president of the united
states november 8th came
and the media said we've seen enough
clearly joe biden is the winner
at that point the trumpian move became
sometime between now
and december 14th when the electors
actually
certify the state elections and vote
their electoral votes we will get these
results overturned
either through lawsuits or through
sending a different slate of electors or
whatever and none of that happened then
on december 14th
joe biden got his 306 electoral votes
and then they
said between december 14th and january
6th
the formal counting and acceptance of
the electoral votes in a joint session
of the house and senate
sometime in that three and a half week
period four three week period
uh they are going to do something which
will prevent
joe biden from officially getting those
votes on january 6th then we know how
that turned out
and then they were waiting for something
to happen between january 6th and
january 20th
and that didn't happen so the new one is
march 4th
which is tomorrow there are segments
of q and on slash trump people
who believe that tomorrow march 4th
donald trump will become president again
why
because the presidential inauguration
up until 1933 was on march 4th instead
of january 20th
1933 that was changed and inauguration
day became january 20th
and the belief they have is that donald
trump is going to make a defiant and
triumphant return to the oval office
tomorrow now of course it's not going to
happen but authorities and law
enforcement are worried
and will be on high alert for tomorrow
because the chance of violence is
non-zero now
they are saying it doesn't seem as
though there's a
major risk of violence tomorrow when
donald trump
obviously does not become president of
the united states
law enforcement saying they're not
seeing large-scale
physical mobilization that suggests
there will be in-person events
that a lot of it is online and for the
time
being uh we are being told that law
enforcement is on alert but not
expecting major violence or in-person
elements capital police of course is
monitoring it federal authorities are
exercising caution etc
there will be additional personnel
deployed around the capitol building
national guard is going to continue
supporting local officers in washington
d.c
and um members of congress who uh
are willing to accept that this is
another conspiracy
conspiracy theory that's floating around
are remaining
vigilant i guess is what we are going to
say is this the end
in all honesty is this the end of these
wild
conspiracy theories that donald trump is
going to take power back over and
in a sense i think there will never be
an end and what i mean by that is as
follows
when trump doesn't become president
tomorrow they might move on to some new
date
joe biden will never make it past june 1
or something like that
eventually the date will just become the
2024 election
that that's that's my belief at this
point in time as these milestone dates
come and go
much like with these end timers who they
make a prediction and the world doesn't
end and then they say well we
you know our protractor was not aligned
properly and we miscalculated it's
actually going to be this other thing
this other thing this other thing
um eventually they'll just go go to we
are taking power back in november of
2024
when donald trump will win so if you're
expecting them to ever say
it's really over i doubt they're going
to do that i think it will just move to
the 2024 election and as an intermediate
probably even the 2022 election where
they will claim
uh they're going to take control of the
house and senate which they may
which is why it's important for us to be
more focused on the midterms
rather than on 2024 at this point in
time
a little homework for you if you're
willing if you're interested
keep an eye out for what they say
tomorrow
when trump doesn't become president send
me examples of
how they rationalize it or what they're
saying if you're on parlor maybe you can
find some interesting stuff there
right-wing news websites uh a coping
maga twitter as it's called
subreddits i'm curious and maybe we'll
make a segment out of it
we got so many positive voicemails about
my interview yesterday with michael moss
uh on how people become addicted to food
in a sense
and how big food industry giants
have a role to play in that here's a
voicemail left on our voicemail number
2192 david p
of course the show is playing in the
background that's almost a requisite for
some of our favorite callers
no but we love this caller and he tells
a very interesting story take a listen
to this
excellent segment with the fella from
the new york times mike
the nutritionist listen
i have the copd i've had a
real bad rad go to the hospital i
couldn't breathe for an hour and a half
on three different occasions
yeah i stopped eating
regular you know junk
like potato chips and ice cream
but recently
i've used just baked potatoes
oatmeal fresh pineapple
and bananas right in sirius and water
and orange juice that's it and my
breathing has
improved dramatically david dramatically
and what he's talking about you know i
should take 20 mils of methadone a day
but he's so right on this guy
yeah listen this i heard from so many
people
and you know a lot of these industries
they they profit from complexity
you need us to tell you what items
should be on your list of things you can
eat and things you can't eat or
here's a bunch of super processed
products that are either
keto or vegan or whatever and you look
at the ingredient list and it's
protein extracts and all of these
different
reformulations of of elements of
different food products
it's that's where all the profit comes
from from making things complicated
and from recombining ingredients in a
more profitable way
and of course different folks have
different food requirements and
sensitivities and may have lifestyle
choices around food that they want to
make
but the best thing anybody can do is get
off of the food
products buy ingredients rather than
food
products and obviously people's lives
get in the way and sometimes it's
difficult to do this or that or to
you know home cook meals every day but
the the point is
the simplest thing is oh you know are
sweet potatoes good or bad now i'm not
sure
just go with the most unprocessed
possible diet and that's what we
continue to learn in yesterday's
interview with michael moss if you
haven't seen it check it out
very very much well reviewed by the
david pakman show audience and i'm glad
to hear our friend whose name i
forget but i recognize him uh with with
the um
that might actually be a providence
accent i don't know that it's a boston
accent
um good guy glad you're doing better
glad the copd
is doing better okay on the bonus show
today
twitter is backtracking after an outcry
for the gender-neutral term
women with an x w o m x n i don't even
know how it's supposed to be pronounced
i want to talk about this entire
x thing particularly when it comes to
latinx
which is something i don't subscribe to
and i have an interesting story to tell
you guys about
when will the mask wearing safely stop
we're going to discuss
that on the bonus show and we're also
going to talk about a way
that democrats without killing the
filibuster could
gut the filibuster alright all of those
stories
and more i will be joined by producer
pat
on today's bonus show sign up at
joinpackman.com
to get instant access i will see you
then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
nebia is a revolutionary shower head
that saves you money by
using 45 percent less water but with a
stream of water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15
off go to nebia.com pacman and use the
code
pacman